[Music]
all right man i gotta ask you a question
is opie okay no this is the answer
well
look i know everyone's been thinking
and i know merch and i we then vergie
too because you know he's around all the
time guys we've been talking affair for
how long like what are the oapsters
thought on alex jones that's all i can
do what is greg opie hughes think of
this situation i mean it's honestly it's
what we were saying um
pretty much
like during the whole alex jones trial
royce and i were saying like you know
i'd really like to hear opie's take he's
been largely silent radio silent opening
radio silent on us and you know that
really worried me so finally opie is
breaking the radio silence um
do you
what do you side you think he's gonna
fall on
i always thought alex jones was just a
piece of crap i really did and he was on
our do you know how many people that
worked for you thought the same thing
about you opster yeah our show uh a
bunch back in the day and i thought it
was pretty obvious that he was just full
of crap
[Laughter]
back in the day and i thought it was
just a piece of crap i really did and he
was on our show uh a bunch back in the
day
but why would you have such a piece of
[ __ ] on your show when's the last time
alex jones was on opie and anthony
that's what i want to know and i have a
reason for ask that
um
alex jones opie
[Music]
okay so the last time op uh opie had
alex jones on his yes sure
2006
no actually and there's this is even
worse and i'll explain why
he was on uh may 17 2013
that is two years after he made the
controversial a year and a half after he
made the controversial
sandy hook remarks that are gross and
disgusting as you would say right over
and i'm willing to bet he probably even
said some of that [ __ ] on your show at
the time i am wondering that if you were
to go back and unfortunately look i
don't have any of this time stamped
because
you know
i just i did it but i think here and my
body was talking to me you know they
were doing a little you know making me
wait when they came over to make sure
bin laden wasn't in my underwear okay
and i had my boot like maybe an inch
over the line
because i've been sitting about three
minutes waiting and i was like oh yeah
okay i'll see you over there okay get
coffee all right
get over the line hey i'm like hey buddy
how about you say please i didn't sign
up uh you know for drill sergeant in the
marine corps and again where i live in
austin texas they now have tsa on the
freaking highways just type tsa in
downtown austin they now have i went to
the kite festival with my kids that's
really racist
god damn it
okay
[Laughter]
very funny jim goddammit remember when
they didn't hate being there they were
fun yeah
i've never said jim norton wasn't funny
by the way no me neither he's not funny
now he used to be like he used to be
very funny
and and i went out there and they had
national guard searching people but
again
real bombers are going to bomb you they
had 400
national guard thousands of police
checkpoints everywhere
he's talking about in this clip
the boston bombing marathon calling it a
conspiracy theory too so not only opster
did you have alex jones on your show
after the sandy hook comments but he's
on your show talking about how the
boston marathon may have also been faked
or a psyop i got to agree here though
he's got a point i mean alex really is
just an absolute piece of [ __ ] like you
remember the time that alex jones got in
trouble because he was filming one of
his employees taking a [ __ ] no i don't
remember that play that for other
employees and they were all laughing at
it yeah
it was harrison
or like remember the time alex jones
stomped on a homeless man's cake and
humiliated him right in the middle of
[ __ ] 40 seconds in manhattan that was
harrison's lunch
why does it keep happening i don't know
stand up for yourself
do you think alex treats harrison the
way opie treated every human being
and i thought it was pretty obvious
nobody doesn't treat him like you
treated steve carlesi jesus i like
harrison
that he was just full of crap i'm is he
entertaining of course he is
by the way can i can i just say
something because yeah gulag i don't
want him to be mistaken he said the cake
stomp was funny i laughed oh this cake
stumped something hilarious i left i
mean it was like looking back i've
watched it enough times so it's not as
funny now but like the first time i
watched that i listened live to that
[ __ ] live listening to that i didn't
listen live i i would watch listen to
the replay but i saw the clip on youtube
and i [ __ ] my ghost almost left my
body that was one of those funniest
things please understand i'm not saying
it wasn't funny what i'm saying is when
opi starts throwing around i always knew
that guy was a piece of [ __ ] like you
can do something right like you can know
somebody who's a piece of [ __ ] and he'll
go do a piece of [ __ ] thing right you're
still gonna laugh i still have to this
day thinking about a buddy of mine who
whaled a fat girl in the face with a
[ __ ] red dodge ball in our living
room in north carolina in a small living
room where it went pink and then like
hit other things too but it was like to
this day one of the worst most heinous
things i've ever seen somebody do to a
[ __ ] and he gave her no warning he just
did i don't know
i still think back to that sometimes
just like the cakes dump and i giggle
it's funny but you also can't go you
know other people are just such pieces
of [ __ ] it's like come on man you
stomped on a homeless man
but he put those families through uh
from the sandy hook thing you had him on
your show after that though dopey that's
the point do not we already dude i
didn't even set this up in a way to do a
gotcha on him but it just makes no sense
just i i look i had to google it i'm
like that's why as soon as i was like he
hadn't
after he said these things
so opster why don't you [ __ ] say hey
man what you said was disgusting
i'm telling you in that episode he never
calls him out for it the sandy hook
thing i can tell you that
i i think it's like i compare it to this
right like if there's people that like i
think are actually pieces of garbage
you know people like on the internet
that like actually engage in like life
ruination levels of [ __ ] with people and
you know what i mean just those people
that like you know there's there's
message boards there's just certain
people that are kind of scummy if i
think you're a piece of [ __ ] i'm not
gonna have you on the show
you know if if you're like hey he'll be
our producer
hey let's have somebody on
um
and then we go yeah but this isn't that
the guy that like you know whatever did
this to this person then we got go no
i'm not gonna have the [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] on here if you're if you're a p
like to me you're saying piece of [ __ ]
which means i think if we agree if we
think somebody's a piece of [ __ ] they
won't be on the show you gotta have them
on the show you're a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] yeah
um
so uh he had a tough day in court
yesterday and i just simply tweeted alex
jones is garbage the amount of people
nice good tweet solid tweet that was
good bro
bro that was a good tweet bro hey write
that one down virgie that was a good
tweet that might be in the top twitter
contender of the year okay thank you
people that are sitting there trying to
defend alex jones i'm like get go go
away go somewhere else
where should i go i mean i guess to my
beach house that's where he's at i i
don't know i'm not in the hamptons so
i'm i'm already somewhere else i am
somewhere else
with warmer nicer beaches that cost a
third as much to live
opie man opie now is so desperate bro
he's he's he's making thumbnails for his
own video i'll show you them in a second
i got a thumbnail maker because he
edited this video like a cl he's
clipping videos of himself but not
clipping videos of like a show like
we're doing like we're doing a show we
clipped segments of a you know thing
that we did
he's just clipping videos of like a vlog
that like moms do on facebook what are
you doing arguing with every xo and a
fan you can think of which by the way is
your demographic and he's so sick of
bringing up anthony and stuff but every
clip of him is him talking about anthony
bro you're the one clipping it you know
that's what gets the most views
i mean we get more views when we clip
talking about you than you do but still
it's pretty good yeah opi i mean like
i've seen clips popping up in my
timeline like
and i got i'll give compound credit
uh they've been better with the clipping
yes they have getting his sh like you
know he used to anthony used to be like
oh it's all paywalled and people finally
probably erock probably finally drilled
it into his head like you need clips
like people are going to find clips and
go ah watch the show plus you'll make
money on the clips exactly it's one of
those things where you've gotten better
that so that shit's starting to show up
on my timeline and opia i'm no [ __ ]
i'm not a big ant fan but i will say
this
like
they're not talking about you all the
clips of ann are like him with like
gavin or him with kevin uh we just went
off fair the other day yeah where it's
just them doing their thing talking
about stuff
and you're here just still going i don't
even care about it anymore why is
everyone bothering me it's because
you're live
yeah cause you're live why does everyone
keep bringing up opie and anthony
because you've done one interesting
thing in your entire life that's why if
i get charles [ __ ] barkley on this
show and he gets starts getting offended
because i keep asking him questions
about basketball then what the [ __ ] is
charles barkley doing on this show
yeah that's a really good point i mean
what is he what did you think i was
bringing you here to talk about talk
about vic henley
yeah
only vic henley questions
and sandy hook you know they had to deal
with some horrific crap and then you got
alex jones trying to tell the world that
it never happened i mean he's just pure
garbage
can you imagine all that other crap
they're gonna find on alex jones's phone
no kidding man but one of the big what
is the thing he is so uninformed he is
also really stupid there are so many of
these lefty retards on twitter what an
idiot
alex jones is [ __ ] done the [ __ ] they
have in his text and i'm like what do
you think
alex really does though right yeah i
know like what do you what's like he
doesn't strike me as somebody who's
really got anything like where they're
gonna go whoa smoking [ __ ] gun i
don't think there's gonna find text
messages to him on january 6 being like
soldiers let's march down there and
start killing people right like that's
not
what do they think's on his phone i'll
tell you what they are
hey daria when's my next interview
exactly that's what's happening i got to
do that flagrant show and i'm rotc boys
right yeah exactly i gotta go look i
gotta go change my tie i was eating a
chili dog earlier i got some chili on my
tie that's literally gonna be the most
embarrassing text the january 6
committee
has a text message with our names in it
because
of this which is [ __ ] great to me
think about it finally part of the
national archives well well
well that is if trump doesn't steal the
pages and have our names on them
and it all comes full circle
i hate you
oh [ __ ] that was like some lefty twitter
joke it was so bad
that your opening monologue tonight
samantha b yeah and then i'm gonna do 15
minutes on dark brandon
oh
[ __ ]
bro victims of the sandy hook uh the
victim's uh fathers of the sandy hook
the massacre
basically said alex jones made his life
a living hell
like he had to deal with that tragedy
then he had to deal with all these
people coming after him because alex
jones is trying to start a conspiracy
that the whole thing wait did you see
who one of the questions was from
footer
what's up footer hey can i ask can i ask
a question now yeah he has a band
who put you through more
alex jones or adam lanza
i mean i feel like
you're almost
you are actually almost
diminishing your own child's death
in this lawsuit because you're going
like yeah alex jones started talking
about me and i started getting a bunch
of prank phone calls and faxes and stuff
and it was the worst thing to happen
ever in my life
right i would argue that the worst thing
ever happened was you know
the murders the murders of your babies
and i mean that's what i'm saying so
they want so really they're just making
alex jones pay for the sandy hook
they're they so
adam lance didn't have any money so the
feds probably let it happen and now
they're making alex jones pick up the
tab
maybe we are trying to stop all the you
guys can talk all the [ __ ] you want but
one of those fathers of one of those
kids could still laugh before the
accident [ __ ] his child died and he
could still laugh
alex jones came along
that the whole thing didn't happen
and so you know it got the best of me
yesterday and i just i just tweeted alex
jones's garbage
good job i like that he got the best of
me like like it made international shock
hold on let me go to i got to look at it
now
oh i can't he blocked me oh
okay i have another one
incognito it is were you making a lot of
filming people in the bathroom jokes
adam um
i don't remember why he blocked me um i
really i probably made fun of him i
don't remember
i'm trying to find his alex jones's
garbage because because apparently hey
by the way if we clip this tape or
whoever if this ever gets clipped start
making sure that you add at op radio to
the titles of the youtube videos so that
every time somebody tweets it out the
title will tag him and it'll annoy the
piss out of it i make the title so i can
make that happen you got it
i can make [ __ ] you
that's so incredibly based yeah okay
let's see i found it
alex jones is garbage okay so hear me
out
he made that statement and he goes wow
people are flipping out over this woo
how many retweets do you think it has
up i'm going to go with
14 retweets okay
31 likes
three retweets what yeah
there's 139 likes three retweets
and 31 comments
the comments are
well so he got ratioed bro is committed
to the bit
uh
wasn't there is there anybody more of a
loser than people that still
like
like
shoot the [ __ ] back and forth with the
oakster somebody just wrote must stay
relevant
oh [ __ ] you know what i mean like i
don't even begrudge people that like
still are involved with like jim and sam
or tweet at them or tweet an aunt right
because at least those guys could get
you maybe a couple tickets to a [ __ ]
show or a [ __ ] t-shirt you'd be
willing to wear right but like
who's still reaching out to the hoopster
like yeah bro that was one of my
favorite bands too
all his replies are always these like
boring generic replies or
doing inside jokes about ona that he
doesn't want to talk about anymore yeah
it's like hey guys you know uh
uh i was like uh doing a linger longer
damn man
kill me
aunt said that you are doing i don't
care i don't i i i literally stopped
reading your comments i don't care
opie you're
he cares enough to clip his own things
and all youtube's rule about the first
30 seconds you can't stay [ __ ]
so he believed it yeah so obsessed with
me i didn't want to say anything how
that 5 000 people watched that ain't
going to pay for your [ __ ] hampton's
house buddy
i did basic regular
um
six dollars probably six dollars i think
that's what it is or
that happens when you're in a
relationship with somebody for so long
just basic crap
i will i will cop to that
but to the point where he obsesses and
tries to so he will cop to that he's the
bad person on the the relationship but
now he's saying but i wasn't that bad
knocked me down day after day i didn't
do nothing to that guy
i didn't do [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] big [ __ ]
crap
in the end he blew up the opiate anthony
show in the end he couldn't help it with
his racist crap he had to spew that
garbage every single day
opie if i remember correctly
you made some pretty racist jokes too
yeah you used to see here's the problem
opster
merchant i remember the old o a stuff
all right you this whatever you were the
try hard you were the
you took the words out of my sorry i'm
fine your dick is that's exactly what
i'm saying you were the guy that always
went too far you're the guy that gets
brought up go hey you know what's funny
stomping on a homeless guy's cake which
was funny breaking people's things
throwing people's gifts that they
brought into the studio for you and like
just
like yes he put baby [ __ ] on his face
bro he's a try hard that's right
day in and day out behind the scenes
they weren't happy about it behind the
scenes they saw
that our audience was uh dwindling
behind the scenes none of your producers
liked you and the ones that stayed loyal
to you [ __ ] them because you're a piece
of [ __ ] hopi and that's the truth yeah
how's steve c doing and he just went all
in blew off all the stuff that was great
about him
and that would be just a really funny
guy that didn't take things too
seriously he blew all that off
to do more and burke's trying to get the
i'm looking at the chat thingy burke's
trying to get those opie points
you'll have nothing else better to do at
eight in the morning than harass someone
you used to like pathetic or racist
garbage and gun
talk and then he couldn't help himself
he goes on a massive racist rant
and then the company fires him
fires him
he blew up the opiate anthony show don't
get that wrong ever
but i'll be
who are you talking to opie you're one
of the few guys i've ever seen
whose broadcast partner gets fired
who didn't leave with their broadcast
party yeah in any any [ __ ] grade
school level lawyer could have gotten
you broke could have went in and sued
them and gotten your contract nulled
and been like look you can't you can't
expect to keep my client without his
[ __ ] lifetime broadcasting partner
you might like to be released from his
contract please
and
like you would go off and keep making
that money you're upset because
you [ __ ] tried to you tried to do all
that [ __ ] podcast westwood one you
needed to feel like
you're you were signed to a deal like
you still have that old
[ __ ] show business mentality of like
i need to be signed to a deal that's and
then that's you didn't make anybody any
money your show sucked and nobody cared
and then you just [ __ ] withered away
and to his credit
built up at least something right and
people got into it he he got like he
didn't take like a year-long break after
embarrassing himself and making
everybody hate him and then [ __ ] come
back a year later and just try to do a
westwood one diner podcast where all you
can hear is clinking glasses and [ __ ]
like he actually tried to do something
so he came right back out people right
away he struck when the iron was hot so
people wanted to support him and they
all signed up for his [ __ ] every one of
these people hope he moved on to some
better [ __ ]
why is erock working for anthony very
good anthony's the toxic
worst one to deal with that's a good
point
why are a lot of former people working
with him that's a really good point and
i don't watch compound now and i'm sure
he still busts erock's chops and [ __ ]
whatever but i guarantee you iraq gets
it a lot lighter now
than he did back in the [ __ ] peanut
butter hat cinnamon challenge [ __ ]
with him on his [ __ ] uh honeymoon
yeah uh years of being like oh no do we
not have any prep let's torture erock
for four hours like i'm sure now he's
just he probably makes less money but
he's probably less stressed out he
probably gets his balls light-heartedly
broken the way kind of friends do with
each other
instead yeah instead of like when you'd
be like hey what can we do today like
really if i can get a laugh like ruin
this guy's life be funny huh